[موسيقى] تم
إخبار عائلتنا دائمًا بأنني
نشأت في
تعبئة الطعام وتغليف الأرز وتغليف
السباغيتي ولذلك كان الطعام دائمًا
جزءًا من حياتنا في المطبخ،
لذلك عندما قررت أنا وأختي في عام 2016
إنشاء شيء معًا بالطبع،
كان ذلك  يجب أن تكون
الشوكولاتة موضوعنا المفضل ولكن الشوكولاتة الصحية
[موسيقى]
والدتنا تعاني من مرض السكري وقد أصيبت أيضًا
بسكتة دماغية ونوبة قلبية، وفي عام 2016
أدركنا بالفعل أنه إذا لم نغير
الطريقة التي نأكل بها الطريقة التي نستهلك بها  طعام
سينتهي بنا الأمر في نفس الطريق
وقررنا أن نجعله
شيئًا سيكون ممتعًا
ولذيذًا ولكنه سيكون صحيًا،
البطل في جميع مكوناتنا هو
الكاكاو، وليس السكر، وليس الحليب
وهذا وحده يجعل من الكاكاو طعامًا
ممتازًا يجعله
صحيًا للغاية، والشيء الثاني هو أنه بدلاً من
استخدام سكر القصب فقط، حاولنا
إيجاد طرق تعرفها لاستبدال
سكر القصب وأحدها باستخدام
الفواكه المجففة التي نحبها.  التمر هنا
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
سيكون ذلك الكوكيز النحيف أو لوح الشوكولاتة
رقم واحد وبالطبع جوز
تشاندويا الذي انتشر
عندما افتتحنا المصنع في العام الماضي في
نوفمبر، كانت مجرد فكرة بسيطة كما لو
كانت فكرة بالنسبة لنا لتضمينها
جولات في المصانع ولكن لم نكن نعلم أن
جزءًا كبيرًا من رجال الأعمال لدينا
بدأوا يتحدثون عنها ومن
مجرد وجود ثلاث فتحات في الأسبوع
لدينا الآن 12 فتحة في الأسبوع، قمنا
بفتح بناء شريط وهو
كل أيام الأسبوع، وقمنا أيضًا بافتتاح
فصولنا الرئيسية وورش عمل الشوكولاتة،
لذا فإن العملية التي يمر بها الأشخاص
عندما يدخلون إلى مصنعنا وينضمون إلى
جولة المصنع هي عملية واحدة، لذا نسمح
لهم أولاً بالتعرف على كيفية
زراعة الكاكاو وحصاده  من خلال مقطع فيديو صغير
ثم نعرض لهم عملية صنع الشوكولاتة من المزرعة إلى المائدة
[موسيقى]
وأخيرًا بمجرد أن يتم تزويدهم
بكل المعرفة، نجعلهم
يجلسون في مقهى Booty Cafe الخاص بنا ويصنعون
الشوكولاتة الخاصة بهم يمكنهم اختيار ما يناسبهم
الإضافات التي يريدونها
ثم قاموا بتصميم
عبواتهم الخاصة وأطلقوا عليها اسمًا خاصًا بهم، كما
يحب الناس صنع الشوكولاتة الخاصة بهم،
ولم ندرك مدى حب الناس
لها وكيف بدأنا في تقديمها،
وأنا هناك تجارب أخرى في
السوق الخاصة بهم  وهي متشابهة ولكن
أعتقد أن الأمر كله يتعلق
بالضيافة أيضًا والمفتاح هو أنها
جميعها لذيذة جدًا لأن هذه هي الطريقة التي
يجب أن تكون بها الشوكولاتة
[موسيقى]
أوه